[Musique]
partir c'est le verbe que paris à
conjuguer pendant les quatre premiers
jours du mois d'août des portes
encombrées de voitures au gaz encombré
de voyageurs 2 millions de parisiens
s'évader du quotidien la rue
l'appartement le travail le bistrot du
coin le marchand de journaux
la vie de tous les jours en quête de
verdure de grands airs de soleil et de
cet ensemble si divers récits personnels
qu'on appelle les vacances
[Musique]
à côté de ceux qui partent faisant la
part de ceux qui restent et pour ceux de
nos frères inférieurs que les nécessités
contraignent à l'essai à paris un palace
d'un nouveau genre s'est ouvert en
banlieue
[Musique]
hop
en tension pour un mois le brave médor
et le gentil minet mais aussi le petit
âne encombrants à l'hôtel le canari
impossible à la plage et le chimpanzé
prétexte à toutes les frictions avec les
femmes de chambre
les voisins de table et les nature
délicate de tout ordre mais en somme
dans ce palace muni du plus moderne
confort il ne s'agit que de passer en un
mois
[Musique]
paris est vide il s'est retrouvé soudain
tout va les fermer ses boulevards sans
bruit et ses avenues désertes
c'est un pari miraculeux à force d'être
un solide qui s'ouvre et qui console
celui qui reste de ne pas partir
bien plus encore comme elle le trouve
rabot son pari désert du mois d'où cette
petite micheline qui vendeuse chez
carven a vu à la dernière tranche de la
loterie nationale son numéro sortir avec
le gros lot de 40 millions même pour un
dixième c'est une belle truite
on souhaitera tout ce qui reste d'une
pareille fiche de consolation avec la
tranche spéciale des vacances qui
distribuera autour d'un gros lot de 60
millions 1 milliard 381 millions de
francs ce qui nous permettra chaleur
silence et solitude et dans de voir
paris et les parisiens avec cette douce
ivresse que versent les histoires au
coeur tranquille
[Musique]